this is not war this is Slaughter we
have uh two of the Premier members of
the Hamas caucus here is Rashida TB and
AOC and uh well just listen to some of
their I mean this is just psychotic
rhetoric but these are people whose
Minds have been muddled by the oppressed
oppressor narrative Here We Go Again
sending 17.6 billion dollars US tax
dollars with no conditions attached to
netanyahu's extremist government to drop
more bombs on innocent Palestinians the
Israeli government has already killed
27,000 people 11,500 of them were
children I'm tired of my colleagues
coming to me Whispering I don't really
like Netanyahu well then why are we
sending him billions of dollars with no
conditions he literally has telling us
over and over again what his intention
is so I'm tired I oppose netanyahu's war
crimes and want him gone too but many of
my colleagues that continue to tell me
that do not want a condition to Aid they
give it to a genocidal Maniac I thank
the chair Mr Speaker more than 1,200
Israelis were killed on October 7th and
136 remain hostage in response
27,000
478 Palestinians have been killed 70% of
whom are women and children and most
Goins today cannot reach a fully
functioning hospital this is not war
this is Slaughter and yet after all this
destruction and Devastation the N the
Netanyahu government is still nowhere
close to their stated objective of
destroying Hamas okay all the things
that I want to say about them will get
us kicked off YouTube and everywhere
else which is why we're on Rumble and
locals but let me just stay on YouTube
okay fine they understand nothing about
war they're lying about genocide there
was a ceasefire on October 6th and
everything else but the way I'm
connecting that psychotic over-the-top
rhetoric to everything else I'm talking
about is they've decided who the good
guys and bad guys are they also when
when I say they understand nothing about
war to be like well they killed x amount
of your people and look how many of
people there in a war when you want to
win you got to win you got to win that's
just reality and don't think that if
given the opportunity that Rashida Talib
and AOC wouldn't wouldn't be happy to
take out all of their enemies and and
God forbid they ever get the power to do
those
things